outs up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 22 of the Sparky
Gammage in series in which make a great
aim and a great game engine from scratch
in I probably retake that shouldn't I
yeah I was torn up between whether I
should say great or beautiful I think
I'll say I think I'll go with beautiful
so take two heads up guys my name is
Jenna and welcome to episode 22 of the
Sparky gaming series and we make a
beautiful game engine from scratch in
C++ so last time we made a font manager
class so that we could basically handle
stuff like fonts and multiple fonts like
heaps of different font sizes and
whatnot so if I want to for example have
a I want to be like I actually wanted to
have size 50 of this font all I have to
do is be like font manager add new font
I can give it a name such as source sans
pro nonsense a file name which is
everything was already here so the file
name is I actually don't know what the
file at the file name is that'll be in
winter actually there's one thing I
wanted to mention with phones in minute
because that was that episode happened I
was recording that like 10 minutes ago
or I finished recording that like 10
minutes ago um it was the fall name
here's the ball name it's pretty it's
pretty big that's why I have this name
thing so that you don't have to keep
referring to it by the file name you
name it like font
eye or something if you wanted to so I
think that's a good system yes so there
we go and then that's the size right so
far yeah and then suddenly now this will
actually work and there might be an
elephant right it'll actually display it
in that size this doesn't actually seem
to be is there a bug with this because
that's not 50 that looks like 32
sighs hmm maybe there's a bug there
shouldn't be because yeah there
shouldn't be
oh that's nice correct what they
shouldn't be an issue
let's try something crazy like 200 that
is not 200 okay there's a bug great
uh-huh
good way to start off the audio episode
because we're gonna be doing audio this
episode but let's fix fonts first what
is up so this probably comes down to
font manager huh yeah see
unless it's always returning an operator
which wouldn't be the case though so
this is interesting very interesting
oh of course no I know what the problem
is I'm an idiot is what the problem is
inside font I can't believe I let this
in there inside font it it's just like
Laurel sighs I'll just I'll just use 32
so I cannot believe I left that in there
it's so awful ah so now I should work I
should actually be 15 yeah it's big okay
cool there we go
all right anyway let's go back to like a
smaller size because we're not crazy
how's it working probably just say
render it with that in fact if we just
put something else in there at all
automatically render it so we might
actually not even want to specify font
but anyway that's that's besides the
point in fact let's um I don't want to
make this about the font let's say let's
quickly make one more constructor that
just takes in that and we'll hop over to
label websites font with my label that's
in like render balls label okay and
we'll quickly copy this and
we'll say we'll let it get the default
one
okay there we go so that might be good
so if you just want to use a default
font you cannot specify font at all and
one more thing I actually wanted to do
is clean right now we call here we might
as well just do that since window does
create the font you'll notice that
window has it creates a well at the
moment one font here it might as well be
the one that destroys it because we
won't need fonts after the window dies
so we can just go for a minute or clean
however here all right we'll do that
before we W okay so that will that will
not cause memory leaks and also it will
be yeah all right cool anyway let's
let's begin with audio so if I open up
Chrome or any browser really well my
face is so exposed will type in
guerrilla audio no it's actually going
to sound wait no it's pretty low audio
what the sound is what I typed and wrong
last time but anyway
good old sound so this is what we're
gonna use for do because it's pretty
convincing like it's a cross-platform
see it's cross platform which is good
it's written in C which is fine it's an
audio mixer library for games and it's
even for games in mind which is perfect
and I looked through some of the samples
if we go to source browse examples
example sound and it oh and there's a
few more goods pages but if we look at
this like it's pretty simple to make to
load in to loading like any sound and
that not only that but also also I think
it's got I think it's got the fear
features thing
yeah so it supports wave and OGG and it
actually supports mp3 optionally as well
but we just want basically organ I guess
why fast but really don't want that too
much but I it does mention some way that
it supports mp3 optional oh that's
future development okay so it didn't
support I'm for three a but that's
arriving just totally use OGG that's
better than every three anyway so that
being said
let's do it so if we will again I'm off
to get the we don't really have to get
the source code for this so I'll be open
to getting binaries but it doesn't look
like they're all binaries let's go back
to predict harm now they're all binaries
windows binaries oh but that's the
windows hmm yes well we might as well
get the source code and compile it
ourselves one off well there are several
reasons as to why not but yeah we'll
just well we'll we'll grab the source
code because of M scripting and we're
not actually gonna use it with an
inscription but it'll make it easier for
cross platforms because we can just
generate binaries anyway
let's grab a few of these things so oh
it's got its codenamed a folder Oh Sam
is us cool so it's got I think it
actually needs this stuff doesn't it oh
that's annoying
see that that's where it becomes
annoying okay let's grab source and
include for now so let's go back into
Sparky and Sparky cool and then ext I'll
make a guerrilla audio Wow it's taking a
while to make that folder we'll paste
that in there is that kind of what we
had before and I don't really we just
have them all over the place well I
guess it to be a depend on on stuff so
including sauce so let's go back into
here you know that's nice dark theme I
like that
we'll go show all files and on the XT
Korail audio we'll just right click on a
folder hit including project and now we
can look at stuff so it didn't include
it into XT and XT I'll make a folder
called a new filter called guerrilla
audio and I think three times just yeah
we just had stuff didn't we
so let me roll this Gorillaz stuff into
that and I'll do the same for the CBP
stained copy all that stuff and popular
name so I it probably doesn't need
appendices let's build and see what
happens
of course Millie arrows so caught up in
that and that's probably cuz that
doesn't exist they should be in the oh
wait a minute they're in where's just
some desk so when you go back back fall
turning to include guerrilla yeah about
that okay so it would have probably I
don't even know what they would have
done we probably just have them in the
same folder that would probably be
easier do I do that let's do that there
are many of them right right
well we might as well have mmm common
devices what happens yeah but what might
as well do that there's a current
include just cut that pop it in here
and then just late the include folder
and then we can probably just get rid of
this little altar as well so we've
changed so many things here that visual
studio is going to be so mad but
hopefully enough long
so let's include this hopefully it
realizes the other files are gone I
think it does okay it kind of does no
this is so annoying
okay sorry now this stuff goes in you
know this stuff oh wait it's going on
something's wrong thank you so this good
okay um so we can just do that watch you
go through these unfortunately but
that's alright
give me a real arrows please okay so
this is just in the same folder this is
in the same folder this stuff is in the
same folder and that's in the same
folder oh maybe maybe not
so you probably want me to go back don't
you
others in devices oh okay I see so
that's what you want that's so this is
in okay so I wanna hear back one I'm in
devices okay and then this is probably
the OpenGL stuff right there open al
stuff I mean yeah that's definitely open
al stuff okay cool
so we should probably include that so
guerrilla audio has this external stuff
so it needs all this I'm guessing no one
yeah definitely so let's grab all that
and let's just pull it into guerrilla
audio because I'm not going to I like
other than I'll put it into XT but then
I'll put it into C into here so that we
don't like have a million different
things in the XD here okay so now we've
done that the hard part is going to be
probably configuring that so this is
going to be inside ext let's find it
quickly
I've now L include so ext open al
well actually I wish this would help me
yeah here we go XT arpan al include and
what was this Aldo H was a throught file
no I hope so
okay build that's uh
Intel some Tara's this stuff needs to
take our Mac directory the same with
this you know good Mars okay so this is
the libs gonna find that's interesting
okay no that's totally okay alright so
it looks like we're kind of it looks
like it looks like we're good
well actually we're not but looks like
we are so we've got a few syntax errors
apparently I don't know or go to oh nice
yeah let's see if release mind thinks
differently
all right um we should probably start
with ya see okay so what is this stuff
ga da that's a thing right
and then GX is the thing hmm interesting
so we'll okay I don't know what this
means
sorry okay so what's it saying they're
expected in an expression that is an
expression that is definitely an
expression huh why does that not work
that should work see when you start
getting things like this it's probably
some other error not actually a syntax
error clearly yeah and the go-to is
great mmm what's the real error okay it
looks like it's all the next audio
there's this has okay here we go
let's fix days so GC threat was that out
in common so we can get rid of that
should be less errors
thank you still tons JC Coleman has an
error yes so fixing these things is a
bit important as well clearly and it
might just might fix the underlying
problem
so I'm guessing these are probably all
in the same directory and whatnot okay
good so X audio GX audio and then
there's this thing okay so where are you
at you gal thing
you're in okay you're just in the
directory huh so you probably do want
stuff like this then Oh guys real audio
and then that's like gotta you it I
don't know what they're having
convention is now this is wrong okay
this is the exit a stuff good so the XT
wait yes this is just an X T right yeah
live Vorbis I'm guessing and then maybe
like include all this what it always
filed up page like what even is that
let's try and find that on disk
somewhere not this thing here we go so
it is there so it's livable this slash
include slash why did you get rid of
that a little bit of slash what was file
alright
okay um codec okay so all you can find
all give it ugh
see this yeah this stuff clearly is not
gonna work with them scripting but
that's alright because we'll use
completely different what is your Java
for sound in am scripting for the web
okay so awk where is all and where is
card act fact her deck is in focus
oh okay so one two three back
one two three aaaghh include OGG OGG
seems legit okay now always wrong
well you probably just need a bit of
this okay I think we've solved all the
yeah okay good so now we've just got
these syntax errors with enough let's
track down UID I don't think that's
mm-hmm if so this might be something to
do with a cross-platform thing that just
isn't happening we might need to define
certain things let's see if this has
instructions on how to build it oh
there's an official seal off lost
download I might take a look at that
does have any building sources here we
go I'll see Meg please don't do that
we'll likely not work with later
versions Oh we'll get it to work January
okay there is a solution
oh okay there is a solution well that
makes things different because we can
copy it so we'll go into ext or the
audio no we won't we'll go into the
place where we downloaded it which
wasn't here either
where is it where do we extract it
anyway I don't think we did it's
probably just in here isn't it
gorilla audio source okay um
build ah well that didn't go anywhere
where does it say this
yes actually and then maybe we have to
that's weird
it should be in there hmm that's a bit
annoying I was looking for to that oh
well that is not
oh that's to download no that's download
actual visual studio oh why um let's see
if this one maybe has it or something I
don't know why it would that's a vision
Alda but we'll say mmm well guess we're
on our own
include when I've got family preparation
application family if we named stuff see
that hmm
so Dec whole spec UUID that's the same
legit right although it is claiming it's
not an attribute so this is this is bad
because I don't know which macros should
or should not be defined and I'm sure
that's part of the problem so defining
it Jo ID okay and this stuff is just
always gonna happen anyway X audio say
what is X over here maybe we don't need
X over here no no no no don't let it
please what it is okay so we might take
a look at the features or something like
that and see if so it says that mmm
truly free good so what is X audio do we
need it and it does sound Oh directs
arts DirectX maybe is it or not well I
see I see
so we don't need X audio then oh so we
can get rid of this hopefully goodbye X
audio exclude exclude
okay that's what I want to say yes
okay so X audio is DirectX I'll direct
sound which is part of DirectX okay cool
so yes okay good so let's add the
libraries now to get rid of the
unresolved external so obviously so I'll
go into here where is it
so this needs to be in dependencies now
they're in dependencies we have X
actually yeah so I guess we'll grab the
libs ending wait we've got our
dependency it's just chilling in there
don't we probably not the best idea
let's quickly um see though gorilla
audio XD yeah we do don't we right okay
that's fine and we'll keep it in here
whatever no see now I want to take you
out the dependencies yeah we'll take
them out these on source code we'll take
them out I should have done that
immediately but whatever don't put this
in dependencies okay this will yeah this
is much better
let's go through this and you must
probably leave that in there as like
licensing libs
so there's Linux and this stuff we got
rid of we got rid of everything else
anyway
yes we did uh we'll leave it in there I
guess well guy then we don't need Linux
we'll leave everything in here because I
don't want to touch it so okay so
actually so X audio is the successor of
direct sound from DirectX 9 on once I
see okay cool so dependencies yes
so let's go into spikey core XT
guerrilla audio with the way that ext
folder so now I presume know about stuff
is gonna be found anymore okay that's
fine so we will just include open al
flash include so open al and then just a
I'm guessing that that will probably be
reasonable so I might have to play
around with the head of all so I just I
don't know yeah
open ya see
okay so properties let's go into here
open al include and we'll grab that pop
it here in to include we what that so
open al okay there we go so this needs
to be an include path so let's just use
for all configurations link not linka um
directories include directories oops
okay good so there's our open al we also
need Vorbis so we'll just say
what was it for bass or something
lip Vorbis include live before person
include okay and then the library
directories will be a bit different so
let's just do this so open al will be
old over now faster lips win32 just this
one I think is that the static library
hopefully hopefully it's a static
library uh yeah I think I think it would
be I don't I didn't see any dll's okay
and then there's this this doesn't smell
like a Lib what what does this need a
Lib maybe not let's build this okay so
that apparently that's still unresolved
weird I did add that to all
configurations oh I didn't have them
website of course I didn't add them to
the input whoops forgot to do that every
now lips my day to you you come here oh
yes
oh that was a trick question that this
looks like no this is our stuff so maybe
yeah one guessing arc probably does have
stuff as well doesn't see that's got an
X in it so it might be we need to just
go through and delete the X audio stuff
so devices yeah this stuff just get out
because then we'll get errors such as
conclude okay so it's still unresolved
okay that's different
so let's investigate Oh V so IV or what
could that be
RV so that's referencing okay but see
that they're referencing giu samples or
stray so let's go to GA you okay well
that's wrong mmm-hmm but if accounting
quit why was this not an error what is
that that is being compiled tryin yes
what on earth is going on why was that
not a compilation error because this now
should be this
that is so weird are there any other era
that was that way that is really weird
let's just clean this I'm getting very
suspicious
okay so ugh
okay let's just talk more so these are
like in functions such as sample source
hog yes sir like PCM total and whatnot
so basically all this stuff um yeah well
I um let's light it exactly so in so
there was one in C wasn't there okay so
let's just so over clear so are we clear
this thing where are you Matt
yes Vorbis so it's obvious here it is so
it's in the ball pit so Vorbis but
Bobby's doesn't have a flippin library
so I guess I do need to compile for this
I'm guessing what was even a legit thing
and look it's good it's like a Lib but
it's like Lal no I'm not a Lib I'm
joking
that's a lot of code isn't it maybe we
should compile it separately into a
library
maybe we should should we let's do it
let's compile it separately into a
static library so this is good because
I'm going to also show you guys how to
do that so let's let's do that so if we
make a new to where I click it add new
project the reason I'm doing this by the
way is because we don't need this for we
don't need to we don't need this for
inscriptions so I'm not caring about it
because we don't we yeah so we'll make
an empty see fossils project we'll call
this
lib forbus okay we will add a folder
hubs well add a folder called source and
then the other is I'm doing is because
it even had like the name of like will
leave so I'm like yeah okay fine I will
just drag this in yeah thanks for not
like keeping my folder structure or
anything not not even putting them into
sauce oh my goodness what are you doing
that's right no that that's that's no
that's my bad because clearly they're
just linked my bad so anyway let's for a
minute here let's just say okay so let's
take a look at this let's let's go ahead
and unload Sparky so well your unload
project it won't bother us with this
stuff let's build this okay so we need
to fix this stuff so all it needs aughh
don't age so if we go into here and into
all configurations and we go into
suppose directories include directories
we will grab whereas it made the
solution all the sorry the yeah what I
made it here right yep good good so we
can just say so it'll be the same so in
dependencies OGG include OGG so with
that in mind
solution directory dependencies leave
all is it's not an all check in a minute
include nothing Lydia yep okay and then
we need to lie a library for that it as
well
now we don't know we will there we'll
just match it all get into it there a
minute okay so now a Connor opened vobis
Kardec Wow where is it
I was anything include yes it is so
let's also add we might as well just add
that isn't it as an include directory so
we will we can just grab the project
directory another card because it's not
because we just linked the files
solution directory dependencies Lib OGG
oh sorry
Lib Vorbis include
magic every of those there as well will
actually need to change them to be this
but my point remains the same
okay uh CRT secure no warning so
preprocessor CRT secure no warnings
which probably change it to compile the
static libraries well I meant otherwise
will get errors so let's not really
judge it right now um so on the general
changes to be a static library no I get
out what are you doing does that even
work i missclicked know I didn't want
static library okay
so potentially uninitialized local point
I hate this stuff I don't know if we
okay well let's set up a few things
we're gonna positive relays clearly
let's let's set the warning level to
must enter full warnings and get rid of
STL checks for now at least
okay so potentially unutilized like a
pointer variable mm why you mad it's
probably just because of stuff I'm
guessing ci is one of them's not
initialized which one Oh Mac memmer Matt
where is it Magnum er
well that's a big one that's a double
null point of a Frick sake oh really
mmm there any way to get around this
without actually on initializing
everything tomorrow too many
initializers is this even like legit I
knew this little library would be so
difficult compile mmm what is sweet pea
pod I'm missing a few includes empires
even like mad look at this code who rose
codes like that Frick well this was
probably written on Linux or something
let's this doesn't even oh my goodness
so much so many failures
oh honey is this too few arguments and
fun what is going on
am I missing something
no this is just ridiculous
can I just freakin download it live for
pitch that has to be like a library zip
of obvious not leaked Lib this is
probably this is actually what I'm going
to do I'm going to show you guys all
this stuff but um apparently it's just
not happening so and I don't have the
time for this there's a lot of news
coming up so this is Vorbis right yeah
just just give me the zip file I don't
need a table all
oh oh maybe I shouldn't be compiling
that file hmm let's see anything with a
main function shouldn't be compiled what
are you searching current project please
okay so there's a few things that have
mains which probably get rid of them and
safe is still compiles and if it does
then it's a shared books iTune codebook
and Bucknell so exclude let's see oh
well we can fix those okay we might as
well do this thank you stream for saving
me there Mac memory so I guess that's we
will basically this is unbelievable is
there a way to just bypass this stuff
how where does it get initialized here
does it get you better to get used just
that wait there as well okay I see I see
hmm well it doesn't even get alyc tor
anything that is so ridiculous is there
a way I can just get around this because
there's really no way to allocate it
unless I do this so can't we just treat
it as a null pointer but we can't
because it's not one mile pointer it's
it's a pointer to pointer so
mm yeah see SDL is off there I'm
compiling in debug actually uh-huh well
that was a problem I was compiling
flippin debug so let's what is it M PI
so use math defines as what we want I'll
just put this in the preprocessor might
as well for all configs I could've just
put it in file obviously but Oh
fantastic
so our libraries complete let's I
probably compiled into some ridiculous
spot though so let's not so solution
direct how about how about this how
about solution directory dependencies
Lib Vorbis and
um out on our lib that's all already
forgetting output directory though
whatever Lib we'll go live that's
actually where everything is and then
we'll put this stuff into intermediates
and it's going to want a backslash on
the end okay that looks pretty good to
me so we'll just do that I guess
and where did it now put it currently
some ridiculous place right I probably
put it in like debug let's get rid of
that or release
yes it did build up we might as well
optimize it probably I'll just quickly
change some of the optimization to be
better
all right
okay good so we've got a library now
let's so now we can unload this project
or even delete it but I'll just unloaded
and get me and again it will load load
this back okay good
sorry um this stuff is in here
really are you really graphics Simon
hello yeah alright so now if we go into
here let's fill spark again and watch
those errors with the unresolved stuff
so now if we go into dependencies and
lip office and live we should see live
for best Lib even though it's the owner
but anyway because it's surrounded with
source files but oh you know what we'll
just we should have just compiled into
bin I didn't think of that I would have
made things a bit better so let's reload
this quickly once treated to properties
and general and we'll just put this into
being
build that
kinda like that okay there we go so
we'll use this as a directory so it's
just in lab focus and being alright I'll
unload this thing this baby again okay
so now let's go to properties in here
into directories for all configurations
let's add in library directories being
solution ok
and then what did we call it does just
leave all this ugly
so back out here on the input and onto
the linker we will add in their orbits
which is our static library that we just
compiled okay and now we're down to oh
this looks like oh okay so this needs
great so leave all this needs
aughh needs more AAG so that's really
quite annoying that's actually yeah the
thing is like we are we arguing I think
we're all game I'm not sure there we
should be talking well why not
what is it what what's happening with
aughh what's our augs situation cuz oh
we're not talking at all right so
dependencies lib OGG source so there's
not much of OGG really there's just
these two so I guess we'll compile that
into a static library as well right this
will be this will be Sigma plays yeah
though it's tiny
well hey that thing it is who knows live
dog so into here we will
and these two and yeah those two days
okay
so let's quickly so we'll unload this as
well we'll unload this and we will sew
all configurations let's um what am i
doing let's do oh yes that's right let's
first of all change it to be a static
library okay now just complaining about
this stuff which it shouldn't complain
about we'll add this in clear
directories so solution directory
dependencies Lee Bogg include I think
yeah
yeah we're looking now good succeeded
okay that was easy let's quickly enable
all of our optimization as well okay I
mean I'm sure this isn't doing too much
but we should enable totalization anyway
this Spock he's all about all about
speed
yeah okay we probably should have turned
this off not that it matters but we'll
leave them off okay cool
oh this compiling into some lame
location so let's make it let's make the
Abbott directory let's quickly load this
in and just copied from that sorry that
except it's late bog
and that goes
all right there we go so release clean
clean well whatever we did rebuild
anyway so good let's check this out now
so we should have been and we should
have Lee Bogg fantastic so let's go back
and delete the release and the release
felt I wish it would have made
okay so unload that as well we're done
let's let Sparky back and go into main
okay let's just build this and yep so
OGG needs more ugh
we probably could have we probably could
have just yeah we probably could have
just compiled into loop four bits
actually now that I think about it sure
just on that doesn't matter looks like
we got one more okay
so I live all let's see so dependencies
we've already included so we should
probably add that doesn't include Tory
we didn't really need you there because
the other thing handles it so we don't
need that we do need to add it as a
library diary sorry
back out here Ben okay
and input
all right ma unresolved exhale symbol
for this book see that is a Vorbis thing
so maybe that's reload so we're clearly
missing that orbits book is anyone one
of the files that we removed let's say
there's a show all files
oh well that won't help us at all
okay so for B's book in it decode a
Vorbis lib what did we remove well I
removed that one as my sublime tax Jase
oh that's not the right file
No
okay um does this have our stuff because
it has book in it right
so Vorbis book so in its decoded it
showed us so we actually do need this
file it turns out let's um drag it in
and recompile this okay that was easy
i'm laura project compiled spocky oh you
thing why
clearly it's got that booking code and
stuff right oh it doesn't have booking
code
well there's a different errors book
oh you think um all right here's what
we're doing
yeah I hate this stuff let's add this in
here let's search for [ __ ] code in
urban follows this looks important card
book and I'm guessing that's not in here
it's not so I wrote too many things it
seems that's because that's why you
shouldn't put freaking main thingies in
to everywhere but anyway code book build
okay Sparky Oh
success okay great
so let's exclude that thing
I mean unload it all right so goods
Bucky's building and it's still
functioning so now we probably actually
go on to loading audio
so this should be quick though we're not
going to so this episode's going to be
like the library episode and then next
episode will actually make like an audio
manager similarly to how we did the font
manager stuff so we're gonna split up
into two episodes again because this one
was very long but what I will do is we
will test it out so I think I forgot my
downloads real quick into gorilla audio
it looks like we did have some examples
I'm just gonna open this in sublime text
well copy this too like I'll probably
just leave it here that I want it to be
you know thingy alright so this is what
they did I wanted to just copy this card
and then we'll make a demo
okay so let's include no I don't think
we set it as an included directory all
we don't need to it's in yeah XT or a
little Oreo girl audio is that what we
need
apparently not manager where's that at I
probably need the you thing as well
I don't know what that stands for I just
thought maybe they included each other
or something one of them included the
other probably I was wrong this thing
that's probably just uh oh yes this
thing so this thing is probably well
yeah okay there we go so 0 so this
weapons up test up wave so cool and it
will just play it apparently so I guess
we should probably try it so let's get
an audio file from the internet and the
interests of copyright I'm actually
probably gonna go to just SoundCloud and
download my last love and dare song I'll
track so we'll grab evacuate and we'll
das an mp3 well there goes that story I
need a WAV file better record my own Oh
or I can just get audacity to convert
the mp3 into a wave didn't even think
about that
so let's let's pop that in here and
export that
we will export that into projects Sparky
okay let's see we'll pop this into yeah
just like test test audio or something
woken up we'll call this evacuate it's a
test wave all right cool so yeah we'll
okay good so now right so let's see if
this works hopefully not too loud
well what happened there is low these
symbols come on
come on
come on
ah this is the worst
come on download it it's not that hard
okay um so this failed oh that's weird
that is interesting so there was an
assertion that's not yeah that's what so
device failed
oh you think why did that fail so it
failed to open the device but that's not
that's not the file or anything that's
yeah that's that's just my audio device
what oh you theme you okay I don't know
why it's why this is a problem but it is
so let's just and release mode okay so
this is null right yes it is oh you
think I'm mad I'm not exactly sure what
to do okay so I don't know well we'll
probably fix this up another time
No okay you know what I'm yeah I'm gonna
go because I have to go but hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of the spark
damage and series oh here we go some of
the stream oh yeah so maybe it's using X
audio maybe but it shouldn't be like
what is it let's why did it skip that
because it didn't release my well that's
probably um let's put some debug mode
and see what this is what it what this
is doing
Oh youth mmm okay um well we could just
probably just look at the co2 how about
that oh well none of them is enabled
well this is the worst
good thing we took a look at that so
this is now wrong GI open so that's just
in like that Ryan no well let's relay
smarted so daebak Marty's bargain
hopefully this will whack oh good it's
working so let's grab the open il DLL
wait why did it did it open a window
why is there even a window what that was
weird
just what anyway um let's grab the
okay now yow libs I'm guessing an open
lips maybe where's the watching are you
kidding me right now where's the DLL oh
you are annoying open eye all three oh
my goodness no just open an old binaries
mmm why as if it as if it's not in there
that's ridiculous
so they bought these binaries no that's
not binaries Oh
does no one have binaries
I'm probably just about it no that
wasn't a window that was the console I'm
probably just about a just literally do
the worst thing in the world and just
get some weird version of it from like
do files calm because that's the best I
cannot believe I'm doing this but I just
can't find it anywhere so this is not
what are you doing this is not good what
DLL files of comm I want to solve my DLL
problems ah this is what I want right
into the desert file oh this thing this
website just looks like such a spam such
a spam side I probably won't I don't
know maybe the latest version and
there's just like this one that's just
like well that's scrolling is this is
the slowest thing ever
then it's like yeah 0.9 download thank
you the other files icon everyone can
can guarantee well if this works it
probably will that you know been release
open al
well there you go oh maybe else oh it
still failed this thing oh you thing
looks like that dll file probably wasn't
as good as I thought it was can we load
symbols for this yes we can
we should really compile this in debug
mode so I'll clean up I asked the go-to
Oh does that mean it was an error that's
why it's that layout let's just do this
in freaking debug mode
it's crazy doing this in oles mode okay
let's steal this stuff there that's okay
okay
okay here we go Oh Isis file I should
see okay that it's that's not correct
looks like an uninitialized pointer oh
gee ax this was like an X thing why you
Xing me I told you not to this is the
worst
nor freakin direct sound or ex audio
none of that stop doing that
seriously stop on our gix but that know
that that is correct I think
oh here we go oh my really it's gonna
still try and use that on win32 oh my
goodness
does it do it often
mm-hm well yeah apparently and actually
not that often
mmm how about we just say if zero
more stuff
hmm
no I can't let the symbols for that so
gcx default free function free
mmm yeah that's office it with you okay
good
so it's freeing memory but then what
happens that's the next statement today
thank you
so that fails so I'm guessing that I
don't even know that thing is that's
just wrong though so this is wrong what
creates this let's go back
Oh what did I do
oh my guess I removed it somehow oh here
we go I was in the other file yes sir
this right right yes Rhett so Rhett is
retinol or as Rhett not good now here it
is it gets set up so let's just see what
happens here okay so rat is yeah that
that's legit
that is totally legit so it's gonna go
to clean up which is here then it's
gonna take that now that isn't that he's
not correct oh so because it was never
initialized though that's why well this
is just weird so oh my goodness
okay I'll say urban device where is that
oh no that's in watching that thing
see this okay what's this but it's gonna
go to clean up so clean up wants to say
see that is null I think I'm pretty sure
that is null that's probably that's why
I can't free it because it's null yeah
see that's not correct
and I would set it to null if it doesn't
like what that's open a else stuff so
open al is dodgy CD CD CD CD okay this
is gonna be this is not even gonna work
but I hope you like my carrot guys
no that's probably because I'm an idiot
yeah no let's say that again yeah well
no no okay so it should have I guess it
should have made it then but it couldn't
open it
okay let's debug this thing I think
that's what failed cleanup is just some
like by-product thing so yes yes return
that okay now it does this stuff so it
does that stuff go to clean up that will
now work because it's not that's
horrible card it'll trying to shut the
context that'll work
that's no it knows and then it goes free
function in that work and then it
returns zero good but that's bad because
it means it couldn't open our device
right that's what it means which is why
it's like oh [ __ ] just sake
so it's to do with so we can't open a
device so what's wrong with that there
okay I'll have to I don't know we'll see
anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of this bike engine this
probably the first one in which we
probably didn't achieve exactly what we
wanted to but if anyone knows what's
going on with open al maybe someone's
done some open air open al programming
because this is really the first time
I've ever used it
leave a comment below and maybe we can
figure this thing out
but yeah again I've got no clue as to
why my device is not being able as I'm
sure it's probably something to do with
actually what is this one okay that's
just yeah we've heard it had something
to do with me like not having the proper
macro setup or something for a gorilla
audio there anyway
hope you guys enjoyed and I'll see you
next time goodbye
you